สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
โอเคกลับมาเจอกับเราสองคนนะครับในช่อง
ช่อง trainablet อยู่ด้านบน
วันนี้เรามาด้วยสีสดใสเลยครับพี่เอ๋
สีเสื้อเราหรอคะ
[เพลง]
วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันจันทร์ที่ 13 ครับ 13 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนนี้เดือนมีนาคมครับปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
[เพลง]
ตอนนี้เป็นตอน
ตอนเช้านะไม่ใช่ตอนกลางคืนไม่ใช่เที่ยง
คืนนะ
นักเรียนกำลังคิด
00:00 น
เที่ยงคืนครูอาร์ตี้กับครูเอ๋นอนหรอ
ตอนนี้เป็นเวลา 11 โมง
เช้าใช่ไหมคะ
[เพลง]
ครึ่งชั่วโมงแล้วเดี๋ยวค่อยไปกินข้าวนะ
ครับ
จะมีคำถามครูอาร์ตี้ขอแชร์สกรีนก่อนนะคะ
[เพลง]
ขยายครูเลยค่ะ
ขยายใหญ่เลยตอนนี้
ครูอาร์ตี้กับครูเอ๋เป็นคนไทยเนาะ
คนไทยแล้วครูเอ๋เนี่ยนับถือศาสนาพุทธ
ศาสนาพุทธก็ว่าจะมีเดี๋ยวนะคะ
[เพลง]
ไปวัดแล้วก็ศาสนาพุทธเราก็จะมีพระ
พุทธเจ้า
นะคะขอบคุณ
ของศาสนาพุทธนะคะเป็นศาสดาก็คือเป็น
ศาสนาพุทธไม่มีไม่มี
มีแต่ความสด
ซึ่งพระพุทธเจ้าเป็นคนนะคะเป็นคน
ทีนี้ครูอัตรา
นักเรียนบอกถามทำไม
ครูอาร์ตี้กับครูเอ๋เนี่ยศาสนาพุทธเราก็
จะถ้ามีเวลาใช่ไหมคะเราก็จะไปวัดไปวัดกัน
บ่อยๆนะครับถ้ามีเวลาว่างแล้วก็ไปวัด
นี้เป็นโบสถ์นะคะ
โบสถ์
เราก็จะวาดวัดแบบนี้เนาะ
มีโบสถ์มีศาลา
ซึ่งนักเรียนสามารถไปดูคลิปคลิปก่อนๆได้
เนาะเราจะพูดถึงว่า
วัดมีอะไรบ้าง
โบสถ์ก็บางทีก็มี 2 ประตูมีหน้าต่างยาวๆ
แล้วข้างในก็จะมีพระพุทธรูป
พระพุทธรูปจะอยู่ข้างในโบสถ์นะคะบางทีเขา
มีบันไดเนาะ
มีตัวตัว
มีพญานาค
มี 2 ตัวนะ
จะมีตัวตัวนึงแล้วก็เหมือนกับพญานาคเอา
ไว้อมพญานาคเอาไว้นะคะ
ทีนี้อ่ะไม่เป็นไรตัวนี้แต่ว่าวันนี้
เนี่ยที่จะถามครูอาร์ตี้ก็คือว่าครู
อาร์ตี้เนี่ยเคยเห็นป้ายประกาศแบบนี้ไหม
คะ
ไหนครับขอดูชัดๆหน่อยอ๋อโอเค
ตรงนี้จะเป็นชื่อวัดนะคะวัดอะไรก็ได้นะคะ
ตรงนี้นะคะแต่ว่าตรงนี้เขาบอกว่าปิดทอง
ฝังลูกนิมิตรูปนิมิตก็คือลูกนิมิตก็คือ
ลูกนี้
ลูกกลมๆที่อยู่ตรงข้างๆตรงนั้น
เคย
ไปเร็วเกินไป
เห็นนะเห็นนะ
เวลาไปต่างจังหวัดหรือเมื่อก่อนกรุงเทพฯ
ก็มีนะแต่ว่าต่างจังหวัดก็จะมีเยอะกว่านะ
คะครูแอนตี้เคยเห็นไหมขับรถไปแล้วเห็น
เอ๊ะ
เคยเห็นป้าย
เคยเห็นนะเคยเห็นเคยเห็นฝั่งลูกนิมิตครัว
ที่เคยไปปิดทองฝังลูกนิมิตด้วย
ที่ไหนคะอ่าที่วัดที่บ้านของครูอาร์ตี้
ครับบ้านครัวตี้อยู่จังหวัด
ประจวบคีรีขันธ์
ใกล้ๆภาคใต้
แล้วเวลาที่ครูอาร์ตี้เข้าไปดูอ่ะเดี๋ยว
ไปดูไปฝั่งลูกนิมิตนะคะ
ทำอะไรเห็นอะไรน่าสนใจมีอะไรที่น่าสนใจ
บ้างเวลาไปปิดทองฝั่งลูกนิมิตแล้วก็กำลัง
คิดอยู่ว่าตอนนี้นักเรียนเริ่มสงสัยแล้ว
เราพูดกันถึงลูกนิมิตลูกนี้มีลูก
เรียนกำลังคิดอยู่เมื่อไหร่จะบอกเมื่อ
ไหร่จะบอกเมื่อกี้ให้ดูนิดเดียวนะคะให้ดู
นิดเดียวเออเดี๋ยวเราจะพูดถึงเดี๋ยวเราจะ
ให้ดูนะคะแต่ว่าเรากำลังพูดกันก่อนว่าเออ
ครูอาร์ตี้เนี่ยเคยไปปิดทองเออใช่ครับปิด
ทองก็คือครูอาจจะต้องมีแผ่นทองแบบนี้ใช่
ไหมคะ
อันนี้เราเรียกว่าอะไรนะคะครูอาร์ตี้
เรียกว่าทองคำเปลวทองคำเปลวนะคะแล้วเราก็
เอามาปิดที่อ่าเอามาปิดลงไปบนลูกนิมิตนี่
ล่ะครับ
และลูกกลมๆเนี่ยลูกอะไรก็ขึ้นไปดูข้างบน
คืออะไรนะครับก็คือลูกหินแบบนี้ค่ะลูก
นิมิตทำมาจากหินใช่ไหมครับทำมาจากหินค่ะ
ทำมาจากหินเป็นลูกกลมๆ
ขนาดนะคะครูอาร์ตี้จะขนาดเขาบอกประมาณ
เท่ากับบาทของพระ
ประมาณนี้ก็คือประมาณซัก
30 กว่าเซนติเมตรนะคะประมาณครูเอกก็
เดี๋ยวนะ
ประมาณ
30-38 เซนติเมตรอาจจะตรงนี้ใหญ่กว่าลูก
ฟุตบอลหน่อยนึงใช่ไหม
ถึง 38 เซนติเมตร
เรียกว่าเส้นเส้นผ่าศูนย์กลาง
กลมๆแล้วก็เส้นที่ผ่าตรงกลางเส้นผ่าศูนย์
กลางก็ประมาณ
30-38 ซม
ๆแบบนี้แล้วก็เอามาแขวนแบบนี้นะคะแล้วก็
คนก็จะไปปิดทองนะคะ
ขวดที่อายุเยอะแล้วไงกลัวตี้ก็ไปปีละอาจ
จะมีปีละวัดอะไรอย่างนี้ครับ
[เพลง]
ไม่ได้ตั้งใจเนาะสำหรับลูกแต่ว่าครูเอ๋มี
พี่ชายนี่คุณพ่อ
คุณแม่แล้วก็มีพี่สาวพี่ชาย
ครูเอ๋แล้วก็น้องชาย
พี่ชายครูเอ๋เนี่ยค่ะตอนครูเอ๋อายุประมาณ
15 ปี
พี่ชาย
พี่ชายอายุประมาณ 16 เอ่อ 16 ปีพี่ชายครู
เอ๋อยู่กรุงเทพฯนะคะกับพี่สาวของคุณแม่
วันนี้คุณแม่แล้วก็พี่สาว
เวลาที่ครูอุ๋ยกลับบ้าน
กลับบ้านเนี่ย
มีอยู่ครั้งหนึ่งพี่ชายเนี่ยไป
ไหนเวลากลับบ้านให้ครูเอกก็อยากจะนอนอยู่
ที่บ้านเพราะว่าที่บ้านมีต้นไม้เยอะๆ
พักผ่อนเยอะๆแต่พี่ชายบอกไม่ได้
มอเตอร์ไซค์ไปก่อนไปก่อนไปไหนครับ
พี่ชายก็พาเอกขึ้นมอเตอร์ไซค์แล้วก็
ไม่รู้ว่าพี่พาไปไหนเสร็จแล้วพี่ไปไหนพี่
บอกว่าเอ๋รู้ไหม
คนเราอ่ะเกิดมาเนี่ยต้องปิดทองฝังลูก
นิมิต
ยังไม่รู้ใช่ไหมตอนนั้นไม่รู้ๆคือตอนนั้น
จะมีวัดประมาณ
3-4 วัดค่ะครูอาร์ตี้ที่เขาจะมีมีการฝัง
ลูกนิมิตแล้วพี่ชายก็บอกว่าปีนี้เป็นปี
ที่โชคดีพี่ชายบอกว่าจะต้องฟังปิดทองฝัง
ลูกนิมิตให้ได้ 9 วัดว้าว 9 วัดเลยใช่ไหม
ครับ
พี่ชายบอกว่าถ้าปิดได้ 9 วัดเนี่ยโชคดี
แล้วปีนี้มีทั้งหมดที่ชลบุรีนะคะ 3 หรือ 4
วัดน่ะครูเอ๋จำไม่ได้พร้อมกันเลย 3-4 วัน
ใช่เพราะว่าการปิดทองฝังลูกนิมิตไม่ได้มี
ทุกปีไม่ได้มีง่ายๆมีประมาณ 3-4 วันตอน
ครูเอ๋ไอ้ตอนวัยรุ่นน่ะค่ะพี่ชายพาเอ๋ไป
เลยอ่ะ
ปีนั้นน่ะค่ะได้ 4 วัน
ประมาณเนี้ย 3 หรือ 4 วันเองก็จำไม่ค่อย
ได้นะคะเหนื่อยมากจากวัดนี้ไปวัดนู้นวัด
นู้นไปวัดนู้นวัดนู้นนั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์อ่ะ
แต่ว่า
หายทำไมเหนื่อยจังเลย
มันร้อน
แต่พี่ชายครูเอ๋นะยิ้มอ๋อมีความสุขใช่ไหม
เพราะว่าเพราะว่าติดทองฝังลูกนิมิตเนี่ย
ไม่ได้มีบ่อยๆไงพี่ชายก็เลยอยากให้ครูเอก
ไปไป
คนไทยเขามีความเชื่อไงคะว่าถ้าได้ปิดทอง
ฝังลูกนิมิตเนี่ยเออไม่ต้องถึง 9 วัดก็
ได้ตอนนี้นะครับให้ได้ 1 วัน
ในประเทศไทยส่วนใหญ่
ปิดทองฝั่งนู้นนิมิตกันไปหมดแล้วเหลือ
น้อยแล้วที่ยังไม่ได้ปิด
แล้วจะเอาลูกนิมิตขึ้นมาแล้วปิดใหม่ก็ไม่
ได้
ยกเว้นยกเว้นว่าโบสถ์เนี่ย
พัง
นะ
พังไปแล้วจะทำบทใหม่
ถึงจะฝังลูกนิมิตใหม่ได้ต้องเอารูปนี้ไม่
เก่าขึ้นแล้วก็ฝันลูกนิมิตใหม่นะคะ
ทำไมมันต้องฝังใช่ไหม
ทำไมมันต้องมีให้รู้จักลูกนิมิตจริงๆก่อน
นะคะลูกนิมิตเนี่ยถ้านักเรียนไปมองเห็น
เนี่ยนะคะเขาก็จะเป็นลูกกลมๆแบบนี้
นะคะที่เราบอกว่า 30 ถึง 38 ซมนะคะขนาดจะ
เท่าๆกับบาท
บาทของพระนะคะ
ครูแอนตี้รู้ไหมว่าฝั่งลูกนิมิตเนี่ยเขา
จะมีทั้งหมดกี่รูป
ฝั่งลูกนิมิตเท่าที่จำได้โคโยตี้คิดว่า
[เพลง]
เลขคนจีนชอบ
คนไทยชอบ
หินๆเลขที่คนจีนชอบแล้วก็เลขที่คนไทยชอบ
โอเคก็มีบางที่ก็จะมี 8  8 เพราะว่าเรา
เอ่อคิดตามคิด
ก็จะมีทิศมี 4 ทิศใช่
โอเคอาทิตย์ไหนก็ได้ก่อนเนอะ
2 ทิศใต้
3 ทิศตะวันออก 4 สีทิศตะวันตก 5  5 ก็
ทิศเฉียงนะครับทิศตะวันออกเฉียงเหนือ
6  6 ทิศตะวันตกเฉียงเหนือ
อยู่ตรงไหนครับ
ทิศสุดท้าย
แบบนี้เนาะก็จะเอาลูกนิมิตไปไว้รอบๆตรง
กลางเป็นโบสถ์
ใช่ค่ะ
ตรงกลางก็เป็นโบสถ์
[เพลง]
ถ้าจะทำโบสถ์
ตรงนี้นะครับบริเวณนี้
ครับ
[เพลง]
รูปที่ 3 รูปที่ 4
รูปที่ 6 รูปที่ 7 รูปที่ 8
คือในเรียกว่าอะไรในกฎหรือในพระวินัยของ
ของพระอ่ะค่ะของสงฆ์ของส่งเขาจะมีแค่ 8
แต่ประเทศไทยมี 9
มีพิเศษด้วยเหรอครับพิเศษตรงกลาง
หรือพระวินัยก็จะมีแค่ 8 รู 8 รู
แต่ไทยพิเศษมี 9 นะคะต้องบอกนักเรียนก่อน
นะคะ
อ่านภาษาอังกฤษมีแค่ 8 ทำไมประเทศไทยมี 9
ต้องบอกให้นักเรียนเข้าใจทีนี้ 8 ลูก
เนี่ยเขาก็จะรีบเขาก็จะเละเขาก็จะถูก
เรียงไว้แบบนี้
เห็นครับเพื่อให้คนเข้ามาปิดทองได้ง่ายๆ
ครับเอามาวางเรียงๆเราก็ไปแล้วก็ปิดทอง
เอาทองแล้วก็แปะนะคะทำบุญนะมีเงินทำบุญ
แล้วพอถึงวันที่จะฝังลูกนิมิตนะคะฝังลูก
นิมิตเนี่ยเขาจะทำแบบนี้ค่ะครูอาร์ตี้ทำ
ยังไงครับ
นี่เลย
เขาก็จะมีอะไรนะตัวนี้เป็นหวายลูกนิมิต
จะค่อยเอาไว้อ่ะค่ะแล้วเอาลูกนิมิตใส่ตรง
กลางใส่อยู่ตรงกลางตรงนี้จะเป็นหลุมเขาก็
จะขุดหลุม
ขุดหลุมนี่มี
หลุมรอบๆโบสถ์
แล้วแล้วก็หลุมอาจจะมีหลุมในโบสถ์ด้วยแบบ
นี้
เห็นไหมในโบสถ์
ขอโทษค่ะ
[เพลง]
คิดว่าเข้าไปยากที่สุดเลยเพราะว่าคนจะ
เยอะมาก
แปลว่าครูอาร์ตี้ใช่ไหมคะ
[เพลง]
คนคนเอ่อเป็นความเชื่อนะคะจริงๆอ่ะปิดทอง
ข้างนอกก็ได้นะคะข้างนอกก็ได้
แต่ในโบสถ์เนี่ยเขาก็เรียกว่ารูปนิมิตเอก
เป็นรูปพิเศษที่อยู่ในโบสถ์ใช่แล้วเขาจะ
มีมีดนะคะเวลาเขาจะฟังนะคะเขาจะมีมีดแล้ว
ก็ต้องฟัน
เขาก็มาตัด
หวายออก
ตกลงไปในหลุมใช่ไหมตกลงไปข้างในหลุม
แล้วคนคนเขาก็อยากจะทำพิธีตัดหวายอันนี้
มากเขาบอกว่าถ้าเข้าไปอยู่ในโบสถ์ได้ทำ
บุญกับลูกนิมิตลูกนี้ลูกนี้ใช่ไหมแต่โชค
ดีร่ำรวย
แต่จริงศาสนาพุทธไม่ได้สอนอันนี้นะคะต้อง
บอกก่อน
ไม่ได้บอกว่าคุณฝังลูกนิมิตแล้วจะรวยอัน
นี้ศาสนาพุทธไม่ได้สอนนะคะแต่ว่าคนไทยมี
ความเชื่อโชคดีใช่แล้วก็มีมีคนนะพอตัดลูก
นิมิตลงไปตัวหวายเนี่ยเขาไม่ได้ลงไปด้วย
นะคะครูอาร์ตี้อ๋อเหรอครับฝ่ายก็ต้องเอา
ออก
หวายตัวนี้เขาก็จะเอาออกอันนี้เป็นหวายนะ
คะนักเรียนหวายก็มาจากต้นไม้แบบนี้ค่ะ
เรียกว่าต้นหวายนะคะเหนียวมากนะคะงอได้
ค่ะ
มาเป็นหวายของลูกนิมิตอันนี้เป็นเป็นลูก
นอกโบสถ์
ทีนี้เนี่ย
มีคนมีความเชื่อว่าถ้าได้หวายของลูกนิมิต
ไปเก็บเอาไว้โชคดี
ไหม
เป็นคนไทยไม่ดี
คือครูเอ๋น่ะทำบุญกับวัดวัดนึงตั้งแต่ยัง
ไม่เป็นวัดนะคะทำตั้งแต่ 30 ปีที่แล้วอ่ะ
ค่ะมีคนมาชวนครูเอ๋ทำบุญตั้งแต่ยังไม่มี
โบสถ์ยังไม่มีอะไรยังไม่เป็นวัดเลยก็ทำ
บุญทุกปีทุกปีจนมีศาลาแล้วก็ทำโบสถ์แล้ว
ก็
ฝังลูกนิมิตเขาก็บอกเอ๋ไปครูเอ๋ไม่เคยไป
เลยแต่ทำบุญทุกปีนะ
ที่จังหวัดราชบุรีทำทุกปีเลยแต่ไม่เคยไป
เขาก็เลยเอาหวายของลูกนิมิตเอกเนี่ยมาให้
ใคร
ครูเอกก็ถามเอามาทำไมคะ
เขาบอกหายากมากนะ
ไม่รู้อยู่ไหนอยู่ในกระเป๋านั่นแหละค่ะ
เขาบอกว่าโชคดีโชคดีนะให้เก็บไว้นะคะอืม
ไม่เป็นไรครูเอ๋อ่านศาสนาพุทธโอเค
เป็นคนดีทำความดีโอเคแล้วใช่
แต่ว่าเขาก็คนที่ที่ครูเอ๋ทำบุญด้วยอ่ะ
ค่ะ 30 ปีเนี่ยเขาก็อยากให้เพราะเขาบอก
ครูเอ๋ทำบุญครูเอ๋ก็ทำบุญทุกปีนะคะทำบุญ
ด้วยกันเขาได้มาเขาก็อยากให้ก็เลยให้ครู
เอ๋
ทีนี้เนี่ยทำไมต้องมีลูกนิมิตใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่พระพุทธเจ้าบอกให้มีหรอ
คืออย่างนี้ค่ะนักเรียนคะเราต้องบอกก่อน
ว่าสมัยก่อนนู้นน่ะค่ะสมัยก่อนเนาะ
สมัยก่อนที่ยังมีพระพุทธเจ้าอยู่ใช่ไหม
ครับใช่นะคะยังมีพระพุทธเจ้าแล้วก็พระ
พุทธเจ้าก็จะบวช
บวชให้กับ
พระภิกษุตรงนี้ให้บวชพระ
ที่พระพุทธเจ้าบวชให้นะคะ
แต่ทีนี้เนี่ยบางทีเนี่ยพระเนี่ยฟังพระ
พุทธเจ้าแล้วใช่ไหมคะฟังแล้วแล้วก็ออกไป
ออกไปเดินทางไปเพื่อไปปฏิบัติธรรมเพื่อไป
สอนไปสอนคนนะคะก็ถ้าบางทีคนก็อยากจะบวช
ไปที่ไกลๆแล้วทำยังไงครับ
ถ้าจะพามาหาพระพุทธเจ้า
ยากไหมพระพุทธเจ้าก็เดินไปไปหลายๆที่ด้วย
ใช่ไหมคะ
หรือว่าบางทีอาจจะต้องทำ
มีอะไรหลายอย่างที่พระต้องทำและต้องมี
บริเวณบริเวณที่เหมือนกับตรงนี้เป็น
บริเวณที่
เป็นเขตของ
พระ
ตรงไหนดีเขาก็จะคิดว่าตรงไหนที่พระ
พุทธเจ้าอยู่ก็เป็นเขตของพระใช่ไหมคะ
แต่พระพุทธเจ้าก็เลยบอกว่าไม่เป็นไรถ้า
อยู่ไกล
ใช่ไหมคะก็ให้กำหนดเขตขึ้นมาว่าตรงนี้
เป็นเขตของพระ
ซึ่งเขาจะมี 8 อย่างครูอาร์ตี้ก็คือเอา
เอาสิ่งของมาเป็นเครื่องกำหนดว่าตรงนี้
เป็นเขตของพระนะ
โดยใช้สิ่งของ 8 อย่างนี้ใช่ไหมใช่ก็คือ
ใช้อะไรก็ได้นะคะไม่ต้องใช้ทุกอย่างใช้ 1
อย่างได้
เช่นใช้ภูเขาโอเค
ใช้ก้อนหินเรียกว่าศิลานะคะ
ใช้
ต้นไม้
นะคะใช้ฝ่า
สายป่าแทนหรือว่าต้นไม้ต้นเดียวที่ต้น
ใหญ่ๆก็ได้นะคะ
ใช้แม่น้ำกี่อย่างละ
1  2  3  4  5 อย่างแล้ว
แม่น้ำแม่น้ำแบบนี้ค่ะแม่น้ำนะคะ
ใช้แม่น้ำใช้น้ำ
คืออันนี้เป็นแม่น้ำแม่น้ำคือน้ำไหล
แต่ว่าน้ำอันนี้ก็คือสระน้ำหรือบ่อน้ำน้ำ
นิ่งๆนะคะ
น้ำนิ่งๆน้ำไม่ไหล
แล้วก็ใช้อันนี้อะไรคะครูอาร์ตี้รู้ไหม
จอมปลวกใช่ไหมครับใช่จอมปลวกอันนี้เป็น
ปลวกนะคะนักเรียน
ก็จะอาศัยอยู่เป็นบ้านของปู่ครับจอมปลวก
จะใหญ่ๆ
แต่ถ้าจอปลวกไม่มีจอมปลวกก็บวกเข้ามาอยู่
บ้านเราใช่ไหม
บ้านเราก็เป็นจอมปลวก
ชอบบ้านนะคะนักเรียนนักเรียนอาจจะงงเอ๊ะ
บ้านนักเรียนไม่เห็นมีปลวกไม่เหมือนกันนะ
ถ้าบ้านคนไทยเป็นเมืองร้อนจะมีปลวก
ครับ
อ๋อนักเรียนครูเอกก็อยากรู้นักเรียน
Comment
นะคะชอบกินบ้านกินไม้กินไม้
ได้นะครับใช่
ทางทางเดินทางเดินก็ได้ก็ทั้งหมด 8 อย่าง
ใช่ไหมคะ
8 อย่างเป็นที่กำหนดเขต
ว่าทางเดินตรงนี้ถึงตรงนี้ถึงตรงนี้นะทาง
เดินตรงนี้ถึงต้นไม้ตรงนี้ถึงบ่อน้ำตรง
นี้ถึงภูเขาตรงนี้ถึงก้อนหินตรงนี้เป็น
บริเวณของสงฆ์นะคะครูเอ๋เคยดูวีดีโอนึง
เขาบอกว่า
เขตอันนี้
ที่อินเดียแหละที่เนปาลไม่แน่ใจกว้างมาก
นะ
กว้างใหญ่มาก
เพราะว่าสมัยก่อนเนี่ยสมัยก่อนเขาจะไม่มี
ตัวโบสถ์ตัวนี้นะคะครูอาร์ตี้
สมัยสมัยพระพุทธเจ้ายังอยู่ค่ะ
จะไม่ได้มีโบสถ์แบบนี้นะคะ
ก็พระพุทธเจ้าก็ให้ใช้เนี่ยสิ่งเหล่านี้
กำหนดเขตของเขาเรียกเขตสีมา
เขตของสงฆ์ก็เลยบอกว่าตรงนี้แหละค่ะที่
เรียกว่านิมิต
ภูเขา
ก้อนหินต้นไม้ป่าไม้
แม่น้ำอันนี้แม่น้ำเจ้าพระยา
บ่อน้ำอะไรนะ
จอมปลวกทางเส้นทางเป็นตัวกำหนดเขตว่าเป็น
เขตของ
สงฆ์ของส่งของพระสงฆ์ได้นะคะตรงนี้แต่ว่า
มีปัญหามีปัญหาอะไร
ทางเดินเนี่ยมันเปลี่ยนได้ไหมคะครู
อาร์ตี้เปลี่ยนได้ครับอันนี้มีทางเดิน
อยู่แต่อนาคตอาจจะไม่มีแล้วใช่ครับจอม
ปลวกจอมอันนี้
อาจจะมีคนมาทุบแล้วพังไปหรือว่าฝนตกมากๆ
ฝนตกมากๆพัง
ก็มีโอกาสพังครับบ่อน้ำถ้าร้อนมากเกินไป
ก็อาจจะไม่มีน้ำ
หรือว่าฝนตกน้ำท่วมอาจจะเอาดินมากลบบ่อ
ใช่ไหมคะ
แม่น้ำก็เปลี่ยนได้นะคะต้นไม้นะคะป่าไม้
ก็หายไปอะไรอย่างนี้ก็ไม่รู้แหละทีนี้ใช่
ก้อนหินและก้อนหินก็พังได้เนาะต้นไม้ก็
พังได้เหมือนกันก็คือตายแล้วก็ผุพังไป
ก้อนหินเองก็พังได้เหมือนกันใช่ไหมคะ
ภูเขาล่ะก็เหมือนกัน
ภูเขาหรอภูเขาก็กว้างเกินไปไหม
แต่ก็พังได้เหมือนกันเขาก็ไม่ได้อยู่ตลอด
ใช่ไหมที่ประเทศไทยก็มีภูเขาหายไปเยอะ
เหมือนกันใช่ไหมคะ
ดังนั้นทุกอย่างเนี่ยมันหายไปได้เขาก็เลย
ตอนหลังเนี่ยคนก็เลยรู้สึกทุกอย่างก็พัง
ไปก็อ่ะดังนั้นเนี่ยเอาก้อนหินมาทำเป็น
ลูกกลมๆแล้วกัน
จะได้รู้เพราะว่าลูกกลมๆไม่มีในธรรมชาติ
ใช่ไหม
เป็นธรรมชาติเหมือนกัน
เป็นลูกกลมๆ
แล้วก็เอามามาฝังรอบๆบางทีเราเราที่นี่
เนาะมาฝังรอบๆบริเวณนี้แล้วก็ทำเป็นบวก
ทำเป็นโบสถ์แล้วเวลาพระจะทำจะจะอะไรนะ
ในบริเวณนี้จะไปบวชพระในโบสถ์อ่าได้
นี่แหละค่ะก็เลยต้องมีการฝังลูกนิมิต 1
วัด 1 ครั้ง
ยกเว้นโบสถ์โบสถ์โบสถ์เสียไปแล้วต้อง
ทำหมวกใหม่ก็ฟังรุ่นนี้ใหม่
เพราะฉะนั้นก็เลยไม่มีการสร้างโบสถ์บ่อยๆ
ใช้เวลา
อยู่นานนะครูอาร์ตี้
[เพลง]
แต่ว่าแล้วจะรู้ได้ยังไงว่าลูกนิมิตอยู่
ตรงไหน
นะคะ
ก็จะอยู่ด้านบน
ลูกนิมิตจะอยู่ด้านล่างจะได้รู้ว่าเขต
อยู่ตรงนี้เขตตรงนี้ถึงตรงนั้นเป็นเขตของ
โบสถ์เป็นเขตที่พระสงฆ์จะมาประกอบทำพิธี
ได้นะครับ
แต่ว่าเราหมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับหมด
เวลาพอดีเลยเวลาพอดีวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้
จักแล้วเนอะถ้านักเรียนมาประเทศไทยแล้ว
ได้ยินคนไทยพูดว่าอุ้ยไปทำบุญปิดทอง
ทองฝังลูกนิมิตนะคะหยิบทองลูกนิมิตก็คือ
ลูกหินกลมๆแล้วก็รู้ว่าเขาจะฝังเพื่อที่
จะอะไรนะ
ใช่เพื่อที่จะให้ตรงนี้สร้างโบสถ์อย่าง
เรียบร้อยนะคะจากการสร้างโบสถ์เนี่ยนัก
เรียนก็ต้องบอกว่าไม่ไม่ได้คิดจะทำแล้วทำ
ได้นะ
จะต้องขออนุญาตนะคะขออนุญาตแล้วก็ในหลวง
อนุญาตถึงจะทำโบสถ์ได้นะคะสร้างโบสถ์ได้
วันนี้ก็รู้จักลูกนิมิตแล้วเนาะโอเคว้าว
น่าสนใจมากควรรู้จักเรื่องราวเกี่ยวกับ
ลูกนิมิตเพิ่มขึ้นเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าถ้าเห็น
ที่ไหนมีปิดทองฝังลูกนิมิตหัวใจต้องรีบไป
เลย
ว่ากี่วันแล้ว
จำไม่ได้ครับ
คุณแม่คุณก็พาไปน่าจะหลายวันแล้วนะคะ
ครูเอ๋เนี่ย
อย่างน้อยก็ 5 วัดละ
ที่จำได้ 6 สิครูเอ๋ 6 นะคะ
ขาดอีก 3 วัด
ไม่เป็นไรยังมีเวลาครับยังมีเวลาอีกเยอะ
นะครับโอเคค่ะคลิปนี้ครูเอ๋กับครูอาร์ตี้
ก็ลานักเรียนไปก่อนเนาะกลับมาเจอกันใหม่
กับเราสองคนในคลิปต่อไปนะครับจะเป็น
เรื่องอะไรเดี๋ยวค่อยติดตามกันนะครับวัน
นี้ลาไปก่อนครับสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดี
ค่ะ
นักเรียนบ๊ายบายค่ะ